hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play fear
amnesia okay so those of you who know me
know that I am quite stupid so I totally
forgot that there were chains here which
you guys reminded me a lot of why you
can't use the items this way oh boy
Oh frabjous day Callooh Callay wait a
min Han let me make sure that it's not
like just specifically needs to be on
the chains and ah piss okay but there
was something else that you guys said
about how the the note before said there
was a key in a shirt but you failed to
mention where the shirt is was were and
I already check you guys told me to go
back well hello that's all listen
this looks like it could have been
something but it's not or did I already
get that I don't really know I've
forgotten
and then this ah didn't work on that no
okay so that didn't work I'm not as
stupid as I thought I was I might be
stupider hmm who knows uh right now I
got a wander through the halls again oh
and I recheck the the crowbar cured me I
bet all over myself
the crowbar is already um broken this is
specifically meant for stealing things
stealing items obviously it's not for
steal it's for stealing so let me try to
find that shirt so that I can steal the
key out of the pocket I didn't see it
out here it definitely was not there is
no shirt out here there's nothing
besides what we've got here and I can't
jump down no that's not an option and
holy hell I'm going to die here
this is how it all ends my life in
shambles
there has to be a key to this door
somewhere somewhere oh yeah okay so let
me try to find it's gotta be like uh the
shirt that was mentioned there was the
note that said one of my shirts at least
what I can remember so I gotta find a
shirt
however stupid that may sound I have to
find it see any shirts in here whoop
aha I got ok i got a key
yes ah all right
we're making progress yes okay you guys
half of you guys are smart well one out
of the 800 commenters is smart okay stop
that you got to stop doing that as soon
as I come up here
yes yeah oh hello Josh got any more in
these shirts of magical nature or no
good I would didn't want to have to
throw the hammer down on you folks see
anything here just pieces of metal good
pieces of steel no you go away I'm not
gonna follow you
ah but a door network my lantern do not
work he's quite dark why am I doing this
seems like a bad idea no well I guess
I'm moving forward now anyway so
okay this looks good all right okay
everything so far so good so far so good
what's in here ah hello now down him
loud down at dhanam someone didn't
appreciate my pronunciation of loud down
at down them still can't use my thingy
it's a constant problem for me ah yes no
I'll move forward I guess who's behind
the curtain a bathtub full of blood oh
hi sorry I didn't mean to disturb you
your bath what did I just black out for
a second there that's okay I'll just sit
Oh bucket you're okay bathroom keeping
I'm already in the bathroom oh ah
so this is uh oh this is all gonna make
sense finally and I'm gonna be there so
let me just fill it up with blood here
that's good enough to quench a fire it's
not luck for me as I just luck on this
side haha [ __ ] yeah what is the other
if I crank this the other way we do
something no can't move it okay let's
hurry up outside get the water get going
cuz we're doing it
rush rush we're finally making progress
I guess the goal or the the order that I
do the puzzles is kind of important so I
kind of really threw everything for a
loop by going into the basement first I
should have explored where I was but
whatever whatevs man it all works out
I am still I'm just too pro for this
game to handle cuz I am so amazing okay
let's get this now I bet this takes some
pretty precise precision placement
oh boy oh okay
if I find a bucket I can fill it with
water I have a bucket
i has bucket take mom oh my arm it looks
strange
no kidding bro what the hell man whoa ha
ha ha ha they're also quite long and
weird that is kind of strange but I'm
not gonna question it let's just get
down to the basement quench the fire and
then get out of here there's a joke in
there about quenching the fire in
someone's loins but I can't piece it
together and there's no one to compete
together on besides those statues I love
you let me just be clear you're flirting
with Dodgers crush sad okay here we go
splish splish yes moving forward
I'm the greatest Oh piss oh really
ah good side Cherokee ah ha ha that's so
stupid how did I know that that was back
there and why was that that back there
for that only one purpose that here I go
my arm look so weird ding dong yes I
have got the key back
don't drop it again you dick don't drop
it
we're almost out of here
don't make a move I'm going to do tricks
I bet no one knows what I'm referring to
just like 90% of my references no one
gets it huh but I've laughed in myself
haha okay now stop that
golly gee willikers mister hello oh I
just happened on a whim to see that that
wasn't anything well screw you then I'm
stupid I thought that was gonna be
something it just seems so out of place
out of such a tiny itty bitty never mind
let's just get out of here it's the end
of the game look oh come on I said look
I said cut the chains oh now I can cut
the chains Hey
you back this off ah what baby you're
like a little kid don't you get a step
closer buddy
oh hi about here now right then oh I I
can't move by guys telling yeah I guess
so um yeah about that do I follow you
must jump off oh no okay well I'm out of
here
I don't really care what happened to you
[ __ ] I'm gonna go away from here and
home in that order I'm gonna do those
things and you're gonna f off okay all
right go team go what do I do about that
I know about that it's like my worst
fears combined in the bath Oh looks
gonna charge him I was gonna charge him
and hopefully that would have alleviated
my problem okay
I'm okay now though right right I wait
oh okay it's fading the black very
slowly oh oh oh man I really wish they
would have done more with that statue
cuz that could have been great I could
have been incredible but ah man I
thought they were gonna do more but
anyway man I'm pretty good I mean
besides it was mostly just puzzles very
atmospheric not too many in the jumps
here which is good for a custom story
because a lot of them relied too much on
custom stories I'm not I'm not sure oh
oh so it's add some part of the fear
trilogy I guess Alma and all that I'd
already played the fear of trilogy on my
own so I know a lot of people
being played but I've already played it
before long time ago I played it already
all of them so yeah pretty much what I
have to say about the game is it was
really heavy on the puzzles but they
could have done a lot more with that
statue I mean it was weird because they
were slowly hinting him um it was very
hard to see that that's what I was
looking at when they did the flashbacks
and the little jump cuts and little
insane scenes and they only did one but
they could have done more with him after
he was introduced and I wish they did
but they did not so that's a shame but
whatever um that's just my criticism
about it's still great custom story hope
you all enjoyed it if you want to
recommend my next custom story write a
comment below so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
Oh
[Music]
bud
you